we're gonna be talking about marijuana
this week I'll give you guys just a sec
to roll a joint pack a bowl or put fresh
water in the bong of course those are
just a couple of the old-school ways of
getting stoned these days it also
includes vaping waxes edibles and oils I
should tell you I've tried all of them a
couple times each to cure this darn
glaucoma i diagnosed myself with back in
high school I still haven't been cured
but there is always hope before we get
into a big discussion about marijuana
meaning legalization health benefits
recreational use and more it's only fair
if I tell you guys a bit about my
history with weed after smoking my first
joint during sophomore year of college
for a couple years I was probably what
most would consider a pothead I'd get
stoned and watch TV right or go grocery
shopping gathering all the best snacks I
could get a hold of I should note I
never got into a fight robbed a bank or
murdered anyone while smoking weed
after college I smoked now and again
usually while just hanging out with
friends
despite the marijuana raging through our
systems we also seem to never get into a
fight rob a bank or murder anyone since
moving to LA where medicinal marijuana
is legal at least on the state level I
got my med card and I smoked every
couple weeks usually I enjoy a nice bowl
at the end of a long day when I just
want to bed out and watch Seinfeld or
The Simpsons and to this day I haven't
gotten into a fight robbed a bank or
murdered anyone while smoking weed when
it comes to marijuana I'm a libertarian
through and through what I do with my
own body in my own house is nobody
else's business much less the government
as long as I'm not doing harm to another
person then I have the right to do as I
wish as a citizen this is a place where
libertarianism makes absolute sense to
me we don't even have to get into the
health benefits or the dangers of other
currently legal drugs the liberal
argument for weed is pretty good too
which basically is it's not doing any
real damage so you should be able to
smoke it plus we're putting too many
people in jail for partaking in a drug
that generally doesn't lead to criminal
behavior
this is a case where libertarians and
classic liberals take on something
really lines up on the other hand
conservatives in the US have generally
been against marijuana they call it a
gateway drug which is pretty much like
calling Gerber's a gateway food
conservatives have scared people into
thinking that marijuana will make you a
criminal or a degenerate and they don't
mind wasting your taxpayer money locking
up people for a personal choice that
they do with their own bodies there are
some conservatives who even now with all
we know about the multiple benefits of
marijuana are still against legalizing
even at a medicinal level ironically
it's conservatives who also preach about
small government yet they seem to want
to regulate what you do in the privacy
of your own home while at the same time
wasting taxpayer dollars which they say
they want to save on trumped-up criminal
charges of course none of these examples
are perfect which is why Rand Paul a
libertarian still hasn't fully come
around on the marijuana issue and
Hillary Clinton a Democrat hasn't either
meanwhile the Republican candidates are
all against it in one form or another
despite the fact that the only tolerable
way to watch a Republican debate is
while stoned the one candidate who I do
think understands the issue is Bernie
Sanders who wants to decriminalize
marijuana at the federal level
ironically in this instance it's the big
government guy who is making the
government's smaller by getting them out
of your private life and not putting you
in jail for having a good time if you
are sick with cancer or with Parkinson's
why should the government or any other
human being be able to stop you from
doing anything that would alleviate your
pain and suffering if you get caught
with marijuana should you have your life
ruined by being thrown in a federal jail
if you get really high and watched The
Wizard of Oz with Darkseid the moon
playing in the background does it really
sync up these are just the some of the
important questions that talking about
weed brings up my guest this week is
angel Teager Angela's part of the Los
Angeles medical cannabis task force and
owns her own edibles company Ruby doobie
she got involved with marijuana after
Western medicine failed to help her with
her
debilitating migraines angel now speaks
about the medicinal benefits of
marijuana the ongoing quest for
legalization and removing the stigma
attached to the conversation some of you
have probably heard me tell the story of
how in 1997 I went to see the movie Air
Force one after eating some pot brownies
with a couple friends the movie was sold
out so we walked into another movie
called contact which I had never heard
of remember that incredibly mind-blowing
extended panorama of the universe that
opens the movie well it may sound corny
but my world actually felt bigger after
seeing that movie stoned I ended up
reading many of the books by Carl Sagan
who is the author of contact and
brilliant scientists after seeing that
movie that stoned moment opened up
something in me that got me interested
in many of the ideas that I talked about
today maybe it would have happened
without the weed but it sure didn't hurt
that also reminds me I'd love to tell
you about the week I spent in the red
light district in Amsterdam a couple
years ago I just can't remember any of
it